Olá minhas amigas meus amigos para mais
uma live depois aí de duas semanas sem
termos nossos encontros semanais aí
devido às férias Agradeço a vocês aí
pela
compreensão
nesses momentos nesses nessas semanas eu
também não gravei
vídeos então talvez vocês repararam que
os vídeos
estavam repetidos né a gente fez uma
edição de alguns vídeos antigos para
colocar no canal vamos discutir dois
assuntos primeiro para depois responder
as dúvidas que são muitas hoje a
acumulou as
dúvidas Então vamos falar sobre um tema
que afeta muitas pessoas que é insônia e
sobre a sua relação com o exercício
físico Boa noite Eliseu Boa Noite Marta
Boa noite Carlos Por favor me dê o
feedback do áudio se o áudio está bem
audível
ok então vamos falar sobre insônia e
atividade
física provavelmente já ouviu falar que
a atividade física ajuda na insônia e
que pode ser uma solução eficaz para
isso né para melhorar a qualidade do
sono então Vamos explorar um estudo que
revela como a atividade física pode
ajudar a combater insônia e melhorar os
parâmetros objetivos do
sono é um estudo que trata-se de uma
metanálise 19 ensaios clínicos
randomizados que avaliar o efeito de
exercício físico no sono de 1 1233
adultos idades entre 26 e 69 anos todos
eles diagnosticados com insônia ou que
apresentavam sintomas autor relatados
como insônia
Obrigado Marta pelo
feedback se o Carlos que tá ao vivo
também puder também dar uma
posição seria interessante Então nesse
estudo as intervenções incluíram
exercícios aeróbicos como corrida
ciclismo e caminhada combinados ou não
com treino de força ou atividades
aquáticas então corrida ciclismo
caminhada combinados ou não com treino
de força ou atividade aquática os
participantes exercitaram de uma a sete
vezes por semana sessões variando de 10
a 75
minutos períodos de 4 Semanas a 12 meses
então foi bem variado a intensidade o
tempo també que essas pessoas estavam se
exercitando então o objetivo foi avaliar
como exercício impacta parâmetros
como que são objetivos eficiência do
Sono duração latência Tempo Acordado
após adormecer que são medidos por
exames como a polissonografia e a
actigrafia também foram avaliados
parâmetros subjetivos como qualidade
duração e latência do sono e esses aí
como eram subjetivos foram relatados
pelos próprios participantes usando o
índice de qualidade do som de Pittsburg
e o índice de gravidade da insônia então
eram dois questionários para poder
captar aí os sintomas subjetivos então
est tudo bem conduzido apesar de ser uma
coisa bem
assim pessoas tinham nível de atividade
física muito diferentes uma das outras
né então o exercício físico demonstrou
melhorar significativamente a eficiência
do Sono reduziu o tempo acordado durante
a noite após adormecer com efeitos
moderados então não foi tão intenso
assim mas sim melhorou de forma
significativa a eficiência do sono e
reduziu o Tempo Acordado em relação aos
parâmetros subjetivos né os relatados em
questionário houve uma grande melhora na
qualidade de sono
autorrelatada e melhorias moderadas na
duração e latência do sono então de
forma interessante a intensidade do
exercício foi um fator importante
exercícios de maior intensidade
mostraram mais forte Associação com
melhoria de parâmetros do sono então
quanto mais intenso o exercício melhor o
sono então embora as melhorias
objetivas tenham sido moderadas a
percepção dos participantes sobre a
qualidade do Sono melhorou de forma
significativa o que destaca a
importância de como nos sentimos em
relação ao nosso sono além das medidas
objetivas vamos falar um pouquinho sobre
a influência da idade do sexo a
intensidade do exercício então o estudo
também examinou como a idade o sexo né o
gênero da pessoa a intensidade do
exercício influenciaram os resultados
então participantes mais velhos e
mulheres especialmente em exercício de
maior intensidade apresentaram melhorias
mais significativos nos parâmetros do
Sono mulheres idosos tiveram maior
benefício então isso sugere que
personalizar programas de exercícios com
base nessas características podem
potencialmente otimizar os benefícios
pro
sono vamos falar então sobre os
mecanismos potenciais e benefícios
adicionais os mecanismos pelos quais o
exercício melhora o sono incluem a
redução da excitação em ansiedade
melhora do humor alterações fisiológicas
como aumento da temperatura corporal
seguido por resfriamento pós exercício e
influências No Ritmo circadiano Além
disso o exercício pode reduzir a
prevalência de condições que perturbam o
sono como obesidade e apneia do sono
então além dos benefícios que eu já
acabei de mencionar o exercício pode
regular a produção de endorfinas e
serotonina que são substâncias que
melhoram o bem-estar e a sensação de
relaxamento vamos falar um pouquinho das
limitações do estudo os ensaios clínicos
incluídos nessa metanálise apresentaram
risco moderado de viés ou seja de puxar
sardinha para um lado pro outro né isso
que significa viés uma linguagem bem
simples assim bem Popular puxa assadinha
para um lado ou pro outro especialmente
devido à impossibilidade cegar os
participantes cegar no bom sentido né
não né enfiar o dedo no olho do cara e
cegar né cegar é de a pessoa não ter a
noção né do que tá acontecendo Então não
tinha como cegar os participantes
intervenções de exercício né Além disso
houve uma alta heterogeneidade nos
resultados possívelmente devido às
diferenças nas populações
estudadas tipos de exercícios e
metodologia então eu comentei né que
tinha gente fazer muito pouco exercício
gente fazendo mais exercício Então tinha
uma heterogene heterogeneidade nisso e
também teve heterogeneidade nos
resultados então concluindo que eu acho
que meio que Óbvio o exercício físico se
mostra uma intervenção promissora para
melhorar a qualidade de sono em pessoas
com insônia oferecendo uma alternativa
segura acessível e eficaz aos
tratamentos
farmacológicos então obviamente eu falo
isso sempre façil exercício físico mas
especialmente se você luta contra
insônia leve ISO mais a sério ainda
ainda considere incorporar exercícios
regulares na sua rotina que certamente
vai trazer muitos e muitos benefícios
pra saúde não só o sono
Ok próximo artigo Boa noite
elía Vamos explorar agora como o estilo
de vida saudável pode influenciar na
idade biológica outra coisa meio óbvia
mas tem um estudo falando sobre isso é
um estudo que examina a relação entre a
adesão ao conjunto de comportamentos
saudáveis conhecidos como Liv Essential
Eight que foram desenvolvidos pela
American Heart Association a arra
Americana e o envelhecimento biológico
né na verdade essa Associação aí tem
alguns problemas né é uma associação que
é meio vendida para Indústria
Farmacêutica mas vamos ver o que que
esse estudo verificou aí
então a estudo transversal envolveu
7339 adultos nos Estados Unidos idades a
partir de 20 anos os participantes
incluíam indivíduos com várias condições
de saúde como diabetes hipertensão e
hiper epidemia que é alteração as
gorduras do sangue e a pesquisa usou
dados do National Health and Nutrition
examination Survey que é o famoso
n coletados entre 2007 e 2010 os
participantes foram avaliados quanto
adesão ao Life Essential e que inclui
quatro comportamento de saúde dieta
saudável atividade física os de sono e
comportamento em relação ao tabagismo e
quatro parâmetros de saúde que é o
índice massa corporal pressão arterial
glicose do sangue e lipídios sanguíneos
então eles foram classificados em quarti
com base nos seus scores de le8 né Life
Essentials e
o envelhecimento biológico nesse estudo
foi medido foi estimado usando uma
métrica de aceleração da idade
fenotípica tem vários formas de você ver
envelhecimento biológico ess é só uma
delas que incorpora nove marcadores
biológicos Albumina sérica creatinina
glicose sanguínea proteína ser reativa
contágios do linfo que é um tipo de
glóbulo branco contágio leucos também
que são glóbulos brancos distribuição
dos glóbulos vermelhos é o famoso rdw né
fosfatase alcalina circulante análise
ajustou os resultados para diversos
fatores de confusão que podem atrapalhar
o estudo né incluindo idade sexo renda
etnia nível Educacional estado civil
estatus fumava ou não tabagismo e
condições de saúde como diabetes
hipertensão Então os resultados
mostraram que uma maior adesão a esses
oitos hábitos saudáveis estava associado
ao menor aceleração da idade fenotípica
que é a idade que a pessoa demonstra pro
mundo né fenotípico nesse sentido de ser
de aparência mesmo indicando um
envelhecimento biológico mais lento essa
Associação foi mais forte nos
participantes com maiores escores de le8
que estavam no quartil superior em
comparação com aqueles que tinham menor
adesão no quartil inferior então análise
subgrupos revelaram que a maioria os
fatores demográficos e de saúde como
idade sexo raça nível Educacional e
estado civil não alterou a associação
entre o le8 e o envelhecimento biológico
no entanto o Mc que é o índice massa
corporal O estatus de diabetes
influenciaram a
associação sugerindo que esses fatores
influenciam o envelhecimento
biológico independentemente da
contribuição deles para o score de le8
então obviamente se você for obeso ou
tiver com diabetes Vai envelhecer mais
rápido vamos falar sobre as implicações
práticas e limitações do estudo então os
resultados sugerem que manter um score
alto no Life Essential weight que
reflete escolh de estilo de vida mais
saudável e melhor saúde cardiovascular
está associado ao envelhecimento
biológico mais lento na na prática Isso
significa que adotar hábitos saudáveis
como a dieta equilibrada exercícios
regulares pode ajudar nos manter
biologicamente mais jovem e melhorar a
longevidade e aparência física melhorar
a saúde geral porém o estudo tem várias
limitações é um estudo transversal ou
seja ele não pode estabelecer
causalidade né causa e efeito ele apenas
pode apresentar correlações Às vezes
você tem correlação que não significa
que é causa efeito além disso a
dependência de dados autor relatados
para alguns comportamentos de saúde Ou
seja pessoas que estão falando algo que
pode não ser verdade pode introduzir
viés de memória e o uso de dados de um
período específico que é foi de 2007 a
2010 que é foi essa janela que eles
utilizaram de tempo isso limita a
aplicabilidade dos resultados para
populações mais atuais né já passaram-se
muitos anos desde 10 as descobertas
podem não ser generalizável para
populações também fora dos Estados
Unidos ou para indivíduos com diferentes
características demográficas e de saúde
então concluindo seguir o life Essential
aid pode ser uma estratégia eficaz para
retardar o envelhecimento biológico e
promover uma vida mais longa e saudável
incorporar hos saudáveis como
alimentação balanceada atividade física
regular e bons hábitos de sono pode
fazer uma grande diferença na nossa
saúde de geral então coisas que a gente
fala todos os dias né pessoal só que o
estudo como tinha um n de pacientes
grande eu achoi interessante trazer aqui
para vocês bem Vamos às
perguntas deixa eu dividir a tela com
vocês Ah deixa eu ir no
na primeira pergunta primeira pergunta
aqui voltar aqui pera aí
primeira pergunta do Carlos
ketman o Dr rque ced professor do
departamento de Neurologia da utmb
University of Texas Medical Branch é
autor de estudo publicado na revista
Science translational medicine onde um
spray nasal elimina aglomerados e
proteína Natal no cérebro é o anticorpo
chamado TT cm2 ass já é de conhecimentos
médicos pros que estudam sim os que
estão atualizados sim Se sim qual é a
perspectiva Então esse estudo que ele tá
comentando foi largamente aí divulgado
na
mídia
lega é muito promissor né esse spray que
poderia eliminar aglomerados proteí
Natal no
cérebro e realmente foi liderado por
esse Dr raques caied e foi feito no
Texas
nós sabemos que a proteína natal é uma
das principais causas do Alzheimer
porque é um aglomerado de proteínas
disformes que se acumulam nos neurônios
o emaranhado né Como eles chamam que é o
tangle em
inglês é uma das razões que os neurônios
se deterioram né não é a única mas é uma
das principais razões pelo qual pelas
quais os neurônios se
deterioram então spray nasal ele foi
testado em ratos e também foi testado em
tecido humano ainda não foi testado
largamente em pessoas vivas Tá mas em
tecido humano em ratos Ele demonstrou
eficácia na eliminação de aglomerados
proteí Natal no
cérebro então o estudo também mostrou
que o spray nasal pode melhorar a
memória e eliminar proteínas Associados
Doença de
Alzheimer então é estudo muito
importante é a perspectiva a nossa
esperança que esse spray possa ser um
tratamento promissor paraa doença porém
a gente não tem essa informação Clara
ainda porque ainda não foi feito um
Trial Clínico né um estudo Clínico em a
larga escala com esse produto ainda não
foi liberado para essa fase mais
avançada de estudo e não tá liberado
ainda vai demorar no mínimo 5 anos para
isso chegar no mercado entre 5 a 10
anos certo então vamos para próxima
pergunta você tá aí ao vivo né Carlos se
tiver mais uma dúvida para acrescentar
Mas infelizmente isso não tá disponível
ainda eu acho que vai demorar de 5 a 10
anos para ficar
disponível
Eliseu zumbido no ouvido direito na hora
de dormir pode ter feito pode ser efeito
colateral da ozonioterapia auricular se
sim Se zumbido dura quantos meses como
reverter e a segunda pergunta durante a
ozonioterapia auricular tem que respirar
pela boca ou tem que abrir fechar a boca
várias vezes eu não preciso nada
disso sim é possível que a zonoterapia
auricular apesar de ser utilizada também
para tinitus né para pedda auditiva para
o
zumbido ele apesar de ser usado para o
zumbido ele também pode causar zumbido
por si
só apesar de não ser
comum então eh no caso de você ter
zumbido causado pela ozonioterapia
no ouvido né auricular ISO pode variar
de pessoa para pessoa em alguns casos
zumbido pode durar apenas algumas
semanas outros casos pode ptir por meses
ou até anos acho que Muito Difícil
acontecer isso mas é
possível não existe uma maneira
assim muito exata de como reverter ise
zumbido cada caso tem que ser avaliado
individualmente
Mas algumas opções de tratamento é
terapia de som terapia comportamental ou
medicamento
em relação à respiração durante o
tratamento de ozonioterapia auricular
Não há necessidade de você não respirar
ou fazer algum tipo de procedimento
fechar a boca abrir a boca não tem
problema nenhum porque esse ozônio não
vai entrar no seu pulmão ele vai entrar
só nas vias aéreas superiores e não vai
chegar D Ana Paula aí tá chegando então
esson não vai ser
digamos assim desviado de
maneira importante pros pulmões causando
problemas aí tá então não precisa fazer
nenhuma respiração
especial a próxima
pergunta Paula que faz os ozônio
auriculares no consultório Você tem algo
acrescentar aí sobre ozônioterapia Você
já viu alguém ficar com zumbido depois
de fazer ozônio no ouvido eu nunca vi
mas não o que eu já Boa noite a todos às
vezes a pessoa tem um pouco de
lacrimejamento ou ardência no nariz ou
tem uma sensação de que o ouvido ficou
um pouquinho tampado igual quando a
gente desce a serra mas isso em menos de
2 minutos tem é mas Teoricamente pode
acontecer mas eu P Nunca vi ninguém ter
zumbido com ozônio no ouvido não mas é
possível sim tá é
qualquer próxima pergunta
ozonioterapia aplicada na bolsa escrotal
aumenta testosteron não Eliseu não
aumenta tá e eu acho que esse
procedimento apesar de algumas pessoas
recomendarem para melhora da
fertilidade eu não acho muito
conveniente fazer isso eu acho que uma
aplicação boa para os escrotal é se a
pessoa tiver uma infecção na
Bolsa ou fni eles não vão saber o que é
existe uma infecção grave de que pega
escroto e pode pegar e pele tecido
celular subcut na região perineal chama
cina de fier aí o ozone estaria bem
indicado agora pra fertilidade apesar de
tem alumas pessoas que e recomendam eu
não recomendaria e nem pra disfunção
erétil tá eu acho que não tem
evidências robustas e que isso aí vai
ter esse efeito tá agora essa pessoa a
segunda pergunta que você fez aqui
é se tinha
alguma
contraindicação né para ozonioterapia
acho que não faz essa pergunta próximo
aqui mas a zonoterapia não faz o
testículo de parar de produzir
testosteron a não ser que a pessoa
causar um erro grave durante o
procedimento uma dose muito alta de
ozônio tá então a dose excessiva de
ozônio terapia na no escroto poderia ter
consequências ruins sim com danos
oxidativos no tecido testicular eh Com
redução de produção de espermatozoide
poderia dar infecção em alguns casos
danos aos tecidos circundantes
eventualmente problema de fertilidade tá
e dor de desconforto durante a relação
sexual então se fizer errado com
concentração muito alta ou volume muito
alto pode ter problemas sim ok e fora
uma coisa não sei se o senhor já fez
alguma vez ozonioterapia mas
é é ela tem uma uma ela é desconfortável
principalmente em concentrações acima de
10 né ela tem uma uma ardência
importante é igual quando a gente toma
uma anestesia local então fazer em
regiões sensíveis ainda mais na região
escrotal Com certeza só se fosse para um
caso de vida ou morte numa infecção
grave
né o melhor tratamento para en de disco
é ozonioterapia ou fisioterapia as duas
coisas são complementar não tem razão de
você escolher um em relação ao outro
e isso é umaas coisas mais estudadas aí
em termos de ozônio é a questão do uso
em her de disco tem estudo mostrando que
pode ajudar a ser eficaz e reduzir a dor
melhorar qualidade de vida ten feito
antinflamatório interessante antiálgico
para de disco lombar mas não tem porque
você escolher entre ozônio e a físio
você pode fazer os dois procedimentos
juntos não tem muito sentido
essa escolha de um ou de outro tá aí se
se você me permite complementar a hha de
disco ela é uma patologia multifatorial
né então você tem que reabilitar esse
paciente para ele ter menos dor para
inclusive ele fazer
fortalecimento fazer uma fisioterapia
correta depois passando aí para um
pilates associado a uma musculação fazer
uma perda de peso né você melhorar
alguns nutrientes para parte de
sarcopenia colágeno então não existe um
ou outro na verdade como o doutor falou
tudo que se fala em articulação é
complementar né sendo que o ozônio assim
como qualquer outro tipo de ã o o plasma
rico em plaquetas a biopuntura né um
bloqueio anestésico ele vai tirar a dor
e diminuir um pouco a inflamação que vai
desgastar ainda mais os discos né agora
a reabilitação aí do cor muscular do
Core ã de sustentação espinhal é através
sim inclusive hoje se usa muito o quê
eletroestimulação Tá certo então não
existe certo ou errado o que existe são
complementos e cada caso é um
caso bem a pergunta da Marilda quais
seriam sintomas de pessoa com cobre
elevado no sangue bem você pode ter
alterações neurológicas como alterações
de humor rabilidade depressão fadiga
excitação dificuldade de concentração
seint Tomas na parte gastrointestinal
como náuseas vômitos dor abdominal
diarreia vomitar sangue nem matese
anorexia que é falta de fome hipotensão
arterial Melena que evacuar vezes com
sangue enegrecidas coma icterícia
desconforto gastro intestinal
tremores dificuldade para falar engolir
problema de coordenação é muita coisa tá
você pode ter em casos mais intensos a
nimim olítica que é as células do sangue
se quebrarem células vermelhas eh a ins
fía renal que é o rim que não funciona
direito problemas no fígado como C Rosa
hepatite aguda e isso aqui já por uma
questão do acúmulo crônico né de lento
do do do qual você pode ter aqueles
anéis de Kaiser flasher que é são anéis
Dourados ou esverdeados ao redor da Íris
né que muitos oftalmologistas ou até
médicos que tiveram a experiência de ver
isso podem diagnosticar carro então é
muito variável de pessoa para pessoa né
então tem muita diferença se intoxicação
é aguda ou se intoxicação é crônica esse
sinal do Kaiser flasher ele pode ser
identificado por um oftalmologista
usando um exame chamado exame
Oftalmológico com lâmpada de fenda OK
posso complementar uma coisa
interessante eh não sei se vocês já
foram pro Chile no Chile H um uma das
principais eh
questões comerciais que tem é o comércio
né do cobre Então sempre que você vai lá
nas nos locais eles deixam avisos para
você não não tomar água da torneira
porque é uma água que tem uma
concentração de cobre muito grande é uma
água mais pesada e que pode dar como o
doutor falou náuseas eh problemas
gastrointestinais né E então isso é uma
coisa interessante e eh existe um um um
neurologista né Eh D Alan muito que
estuda bastante aí a questão da
bioquímica cerebral que é o Dr walch que
fala da importância aí do Balanço entre
cobra e Zinco tá na questão da
neurotransmissão e que hoje já existem
evidências importantes de que uma das
questões que leva a depressão pós-parto
é o desbalance Né o o o cobre está muito
acima do Zino é gestante tem tendência a
acumular cobre ess que T querendo dizer
E o Chile tem muitas minas de cobre é um
das principais atividades econômicas
dele poro que eles tem muito cobre a
água então ver o zinco o zinco sempre
tem que tá acima do cobre aí nos seus
exames laboratoriais né Para que você po
pode estar os dois no mesmo valor não
tem um para um eu gosto sempre um
pouquinho a mais 20%
ah aí a pessoa não quis se identificar
Dr Alan um filho e mãe Preciso
normalizar vitamina D Qual que é a dose
para homem de que pesa 59 kg e tem 1,76
2 7 anos de idade vitamina D no sangue
de 30 e a mãe pesa
58 e tem uma altura de aproximadamente
de 1 60 tem mais de 50 anos de idade tem
vitamina D de 20 ó Geralmente eu não
faço essas contas para repor vitamina D
não tá mas eu vou falar para vocês que
existe sim uma uma conta matemática que
você
pega a dose que você vai dar seria igual
o nível desejado de vitamina D no sangue
menos o nível atual vezes o peso
dividido por 2,5 eu eu não uso
geralmente essa fórmula Geralmente eu
passo 5.000 unidades de 2.000 a 10.000
por dia dependendo do caso
tá mas se você fosse fazer o cálculo tá
ou a pessoa que você comentou
aí que você quer deixar o digamos quer
deixar a vitamina D da pessoa
50 tá E ela tá atualmente com nível 30
então seria 50 - 30 20 x
59 tá que é o peso em Kg né do do homem
no caso dividido por 2,5 daria eh 472
unidades por dia só que essa conta para
mim é meio furada porque muitas vezes
você não vê Esse aumento do jeito que tá
falando aqui tá então eu daria por volta
de 2.000 unidades por dia ou até 5.000
unidades por dia paraas duas pessoas
depois eu mediria de novo
Tá mas fazendo a a conta seria 472
unidades por dia pro homem e paraa mãe
seria 696 unidades por dia mas eu não eu
não usaria essa conta não usaria logo
uma dose fixa e depois eu faria o ajuste
de acordo com o segundo exame de sangue
vamos paraa próxima
pergunta você falou que deve-se tomar
duas colheres de hóa de coco por dia se
não pode dar diarreia não eu falei que
além de duas colheres de hóa de coco por
dia pode dar diarreia e vômito alguns
casos Tá mas pode-se tomar mais de dois
após algumas horas Depende da pessoa tá
isso é muito
variável se você tá aumentando aos
pouquinhos a dose do Óleo de coco você
pode tolerar dose mais alas sim tá mas é
bom se aumentar aos pouquinhos pessoas
que têm a a mutação do apo e 4 tem que
tomar mais cuidado com o óleo de
coco então se você tiver acesso ao exame
genético e tiver uma cópia do apo E4
duas cópias não passe de duas colheres
de sopa por dia de óleo de
coco agora se você não tiver por4 você
pode consumir quantidades
maiores eu acho que dificilmente é
necessário eh a além de duas colheres de
sopa de óleo de coco por dia não vejo
tanta necessidade disso a não ser que
você tenha muita certeza que você não
não tem problema de
intolerância e que você não tenha essa
mutação do E4
ã quais seriam os danos da pessoa com
resultado de exame de cobre acima do
máximo já foi comentado né comentamos aí
no no na pergunta anterior tá
Marilda passar pro próximo
aqui Manuel pronto pessoa que quando usa
a roupa íntima que aperta quando alguma
coisa aperta o seu corpo fica empolado e
avermelhado mas depois a maca some e
causa alergia Teria algum medicamento ou
suplemento mais indicado Às vezes o
corpo todo fica
alérgico isso pode acontecer
eh tanto pelo tecido que você tá
utilizando Quanto pode ser também por
questão de pressão atrito do tecido que
pode provocar e uma ação de estamina no
corpo que lembra muito uma reação
alérgica mas não necessariamente é uma
alergia Tá mas pode ser sim alergia o
tecido ou pode ser só uma consequência
do atrito causando
de dos comuns né de farmácia né que pode
ser por exemplo a cetirizina a
Loratadina difenidramina tem vários
outros ou você pode usar naturais que é
quercetina vitamina C A Ortiga de oica e
também a bromelaína você pode usar o
ômega-3 que tem ação antiinflamatória
que ajuda também casos mais graves você
pode usar corticoide só corticoide tem
muitos efeitos colaterais tem que ser
acompanhado por médico
Então seria basicamente isso a vitamina
C também acho eu comentei da vitamina C
A vitamina C que acetina Tiga deica e
bromelina seria os principais
naturais também evite roupas apertadas
Procure utilizar roupas de algodão né
que é melhor que o material menos
propenso a irritação na pele mantém a
pele hidratada e evite sabões
ou sabonetes que sejam eh cheios de
produtos químicos usam mais produtos
naturais
[Música]
tá ã vamos pra próxima
pergunta Marilda fibrinogênio
tireoglobulina rdw aos exames de sangue
coletados no 10mo dia pós-operatório de
artrose nos dedos dos pés pode ser
devido à cirurgia podem ser sim
[Música]
tá por exemplo fibrinogênio
é uma proteína de fase aguda né Ele é
liberado pelo fígado e é convertido em
fibrina se você forma um
coágulo e o nível de fibrinogênio pode
aumentar sim resposta a processos
inflamatórios incluindo
cirurgias isso pode persistir durante
semanas após a cirurgia tá dependendo da
extensão da lesão do procedimento a
tiroglobulina é uma proteína precursora
dos hormônios tiroidianos é produzido
pel da glândula
tiroidiana ela tá mais associada a
problemas de tireóide mas é possível que
os seus níveis aumentem por estresse
Agudo fisiológico da
cirurgia porque o stresse cirúrgico pode
levar a alterações temporárias na função
tiroidiana resultando em níveis mais
altos de tiroglobulina porque a glândula
tiroidiana mais estressada pode ter que
produzir mais
hormônio isso é menos comum no entanto
OK agora essa alteração do tamanho das
hemácias que é o rdw rdw é uma medida de
homogeneidade do formato das hemácias
ela ele mede a variação no tamanho dos
glóbulos vermelhos então valores
aumentados de
rdw podem indicar uma produção acelerada
ou anormal de células sanguíneas que
podem acontecer após a cirurgia mais
comummente devido a perda de sangue ou
estresse fisiológico então isso pode
causar sim um aumento do
rdw tá então pode ser por causa da
cirurgia
também o tempo de normalização desses
marcadores é muito variável pode ser
dias ou semanas de acordo com a
intensidade do trauma e se isso não
melhorar dentro de alguns meses tem que
ser reavaliado para ver se não tem outra
doença por trás disso
daí bem vamos para próxim uma
pergunta alguns médicos dizem que o
sangue
ácido ocasiona muitos problemas de saúde
outros dizem que isso não existe pois
acidez sanguínea levaria ao óbito
imediato Qual a minha opinião bem
Depende do que está chamando de acidez
sanguínea tá porque acidez sanguínea
pode significar coisas diferentes para
pessoas diferentes Porque que o PH do
sangue ele fica muito bem regulado entre
735 e 745 então ele é muito
pouco variável uma pessoa que tá com pH
baixo 7.35 provavelmente tá
hospitalizada tá porque você tá com uma
acidez metabólica e essa pessoa
dificilmente estaria bem em casa ou
mesmo uma pessoa que tá com alcalose
metabólica que tá com ph acima de
7.45 o corpo humano tem mecanismos
sofisticados para regular esse PH agora
o que as pessoas às vezes confundem é
que muitas vezes você pode est sim com
excesso do p a ácido do organismo que é
diferente da acidez no sangue Às vez
você tá com uma estresse fisiológico
causando o quê perda de massa óssea para
poder tamponar o sangue com magnésio
para equilibrar esse PH aí então isso é
diferente de tá com sangue ácido isso é
um pouco complicado para algumas pessoas
entenderem então Mas o médico tá falando
de acidose no sangue ele pode tá falando
do quê de uma tendência acidose eu pode
tá falando uma
acidose já instalada Então você tem que
saber do que que a pessoa tá falando
quando ela comenta sobre
[Música]
isso e se você o PH abaixar abaixo de
6.8 geralmente você morre tá é muito
difícil uma pessoa ficar viva com ph
sanguíneo abaixo de 6.8 ou acima de
7.8 e as condições mais comuns que levam
a acidose metabólica a insuficiência
renal diabetes
compensado uso excessivo de alguns
medicamentos entos e os sintomas que a
pessoa tem com acidose metabólica é uma
compensação respiratória dessa acidez
que é causa hiperventilação com falta de
ar né pessoa respira muito rápido e sem
falta de ar pode ter confusão mental e
entrar em como em casos mais
graves
Ok então essa questão do do pul Ácido é
diferente do da questão da acidificação
do sangue as pessoas confundem uma coisa
com a outra porque isso é um assunto
complexo e tem que ter um certo
conhecimento de fisiologia para entender
isso Ficou claro para
você eu acho que você tá ao vivo né
Marilda se tiver você pode complementar
a pergunta caso não tenha entendido
algo quer comprimentar alguma coisa
sobre isso
tá
César Possivelmente relacionado à
disbiose sempre no período noturno por
volta das 21 horas iniciam-se os gases
intestinais situação que perdura por
mais de 1
hora podemos associar isso com efeito de
algum alimento ingerido no almoço
depende do alimento ou poderia ser algo
do jantar depende da hora que você
almoça depende da hora que você janta e
Depende do que você comeu também no
almoço e no jantar tem alguns alimentos
que demoram para produzir gases né que
são lentos a digestão
geralmente são os alimentos ricos em
fibra o alimento mais conhecido é o
feijão né que ele causa muitos gases é
totalmente possível que esse feijão do
almoço cause gases à noite outro
alimento Como é o brócolis milho vários
outros vegetais que tenham aí muita
fibra pode causar gases várias horas
depois que você comer no almoço mas se
você jantar mais cedo por volta das 18
horas ou 19 horas é possível que esses
alimentos que você consumir nesse
horário podde est causando os gases
poucas horas depois e atrapalhando o
sono então pode ser muito bem uma
disbiose intestinal sim pode até ser um
problema de cibo né que é a proliferação
excessiva de de bactérias no intestino
delgado eh tem pessoas que tem esse
desequilíbrio das bactérias e mesmo
comendo alimento saudáveis Às vezes tem
muitos gases por conta desse excesso de
bactérias os alimentos mais propensos a
causar G são feijão as
outras leguminosas como ervilha lentilha
e grão de bico e vegetais como brócolis
cov de bruxela cebola alho cov e Flor
cereais integrais ovos também tende a da
gases alguns adoçantes artificiais
especialmente temol né
os açúcares derivados poliois aí né os
adoçantes derivados
polióis algumas frutas ricas em frutose
e bebidas eficazes comer muito rápido
sem mastigar direito também provoca mais
gases ingerir muita quantidade de comida
numa refeição só beber bebida gasificada
junto da refeição então é importante
você controlar isso daí ter um diário
alimentar um registro detalhado do que
que você come em cada refeição para
correlacionar com sintomas que você
apresenta isso pode ajudar a identificar
padrões e alimentos
problemáticos Então é bom experimentar
reduz eliminar temporariamente os
alimentos que são aí os suspeitos e
Observar se você teve melhora nos
sintomas então para isso é fundamental
fazer o diário
alimentar também considere ajustar o
horário do jantar ou a composição dessa
refeição para ver se tem mudança no
sintomas e se persistirem os sintomas
procure o médico né probióticos podem
ajudar em alguns casos mas depende tem
casos que o probiótico até piora tem que
tomar cuidado com isso se você for usar
probiótico é melhor você usar o S obes
né os sbo que tem menos risco de piorar
os gases
tá próxima
pergunta César a presença de mucas fes
já é uma indicação de infecção
intestinal ou somente uma reação
alérgica pode ser infecção intestinal
pode ser reação alérgica mas pode ser
outras coisas tá muco em pequenas
quantidades é
normal e geralmente essa quantidade
receptível a oleo nu quando o múc tá
visível
eh pode ser outras coisas que não seja
infecção alergia pode ser por exemplo
parasita pode ser intolerância ou
alergia alimentar pode ser intestino
irritável pode ser algumas doenças
inflamatórias intestinais como Cromo
retocolite
cativa pode ser uso de alimentos
excessivamente apimentados ou
condimentados pode ser pessoas que TM
constipação intestinal também tem mais
muco e ente pode ser câncer
intestinal e é importante observar os
outros sintomas Associados como o caso
diarreia persistente dor abdominal sang
nas feses que se tiverem Associados
é são sinais de alerta aí
né muitas vezes é importante fazer uma
avaliação de colonoscopia e se a
colonoscopia via normal e fazer aí os
exames funcionais intestinais né como é
o caso aí do coproma do Lemos
Fernando Doutor sobre ingestão de área
de vitaminas e minerais poderia indicar
um livro ou fonte com as recomendações
de gestão
diária aí eu recomendo você compre um
livro de de ortomolecular Fernando para
você estudar esse assunto se você tiver
realmente muito interesse estudar de uma
maneira aprofundada então você procura
na internet B sites tá eu tenho um livro
aqui que eu gosto muito que é o
eh é um livro que eu comprei há um tempo
atrás alguns anos atrás que é o
nutritional medicine Mas ele é muito
caro para um lego comprar tá que é um
livro bem assim pesado o preço dele mas
é um livro excelente tá caso você tá com
dinheiro sobrando aí para eu comprar
isso vou ganhar de an V vou mostrar para
vocês a o livro aqui pera aí eu tenho
que colocar só mentinho pera aí
Pronto pode mostrar o livro pera aí é do
Alan gab mas esse é um livro mais para
médico tá mas a grossura do livro tá mas
aí caso você não tenha condição de
comprar esse livro você pode
comprar um desses livros menores aí dos
autores nacionais de medicina autom
molecular procura na Amazon que tem
vários
livros eh Doutor Quais são os opções de
tratamento para um paciente que teve
câncer de próstata realizou a retirada
da próstata eu tô entendendo que fez a
retirada mais a radioterapia Zerou PSA
em 15 anos depois na presena PSA entre 5
e
se isso leva a crer que tá tendo
recidiva da
doença Esse aqui também ó quer mostrar
outu livro
aí Não mas esse é livro profissional né
na de nutrição
né tá
bem falando desse caso que teve recidivo
do PSA 15 anos depois Muito
provavelmente ele teve uma uma recidiva
da doença ele pode fazer uma nova
radioterapia mas antes disso é
Inconveniente ele fazer um exame chamado
Pet C psma tá que é um tipo de Pet Scan
né que é um tipo de tomografia por
emissão de pósitrons que usa um marcador
chamado psma é para ver se tá tendo
metástase a distância do câncer de
próstata
e nesses casos opção de tratamento
geralmente ou é radioterapia de resgate
ou é bloqueio hormonal ou pode ser
também eh Além de privação androgênica
que é bloqueio hormonal alguns agentes
mais novos que é o caso da nalot amida
da apalutamida dar rolot amida né que
você pode usar aí em combinação com a
terapia de bloqueio hormonal mais
ortodoxa e tem também existe hoje para
metasis ósseas o uso do rádio
223 uso do lutes
177 alguns casos também de quimioterapia
que são muito limitados mas existem e
imunoterapia tá então existe várias
opções aí para pessoas que tiveram
recidiva anos depois de rádio e cirurgia
de prostatectomia radicala Boa noite
Estela Mares prazer tê-la aqui
conosco Maria Helena a vitamina B1 pode
interferir ou liberar
histamina bem a B1 na verdade ela pode
ajudar no tratamento de pessoas que T
tolerancia
estamina ela é um cofator importante
para as enzimas envolvidos na degradação
e eliminação da estamina no
organismo alguns estudos sugere que a
suplementação com B1 pode ajudar a
reduzir os níveis de
histamina então o efeito dela é mais de
tratamento e não de piorar a
intolerância
amín alguns estudos laboratoriais
indicam que a B1 a tiamina pode ter um
efeito inibidor sobre a de amino oxidase
que é responsável
eh pela degradação da
estamina Então nesse caso seria icamente
o caso da B1 piorar aí a os sintomas de
histamina Porém esse efeito foi
observado apenas em condições des
laboratoriais e a sua relevância Clínica
não tá clara ainda um estudo em ratos
com deficiência de tiamina mostrou
alterações nos níveis deste agente
estamina em diferentes regiões do
cérebro incluindo um aumento
significativo no
hipotálamo e isso poderia sugerir que a
deficiência de vitamina B1 causaria uma
um problema no sistema histaminérgico
Central então a B1 a princípio é
tratamento você pode usar ela com
protocolo de suplementação para pessoas
com intolerância
estamina porque ela Poderia ajudar a
apoiar ou dar suporte às vias de
degradação da
estamina então tem algumas informações
contraditórias né sobre o efeito da B1
mas a princípio a B1 é interessante não
seria uma causa de piora dos sintomas de
estamina no
organismo pra próxima pergunta
aqui Maria Helena pressão arterial está
caindo muito fica em t de 8 por C no
coração não tem nada de errado o
diferente que introduzi foi gaba el
teanina Ach aganda e entil
hidroxiprolina e óleo de então gaba pode
baixar pressão arterial ele ter anina
pode ter efeito de redução também de
pressão arterial a chagando é a mesma
coisa os outros agentes aí que é a
hidroxi hidroxiprolina prolina oó de
copaíba não causam queda de pressão
arterial então se você tá com pressão
muito baixa suspenda esses ativos aí que
provavelmente eles são a causa do seu
problema porém toma bastante água
aumente o seu consumo de sal integral e
se os sintomas persistirem procure
assistência médica
Ok
[Música]
eh Maria Helena suro fisiológico 0,9%
dura 3 dias após aberto Isso é verdade
depende Mari se você tiver usando na sua
casa eu acho que você pode usar até 10
dias tá num hospital com certeza ninguém
vai usar um soro fisiológico aberto né
mas na sua casa se for para limpar uma
ferida ou para fazer uma inalação você
pode est reutilizando mesmo soro por 10
dias e se tiver na geladeira até mais
tempo tá então É depende do do tipo de
uso que você tá fazendo para o o soro
fisiológico ru Elita o doutor recomenda
a vacina contra a pneumonia a princípio
sim porque ela é uma vacina convencional
sem tecnologia de RNA mensageiro tá tá
então eu não vejo problema nessa vacina
ainda apesar de achar que elas deve ser
utilizada só para pessoas que estão
imunodeprimidas ou pessoas de idade Tá
mas não recomendaria que todas as
pessoas fizessem essa vacina da pne
Mocóca
[Música]
não enquanto eles não introduziram a
tecnologia do RNA mensageiro ou
adenovírus modificado nessas vacinas eu
não tenho porque não
contra não indicar né Não teria porque
contraindicar isso
daí Thiago suor pode indicar algo sobre
a saúde minhas camisetas brancas ficam
com manchas amarelas na axila mesmo eu
usando desodorante natural e sem
alumínio o suor pode dar informações
sobre a saúde sim
eh logicamente Suá é um processo natural
importante no corpo mais pessoas que têm
por exemplo sudorese excessiva que é
hiperhidrose pode est associado a
algumas situações de saúde pode ser só
um problema realmente e da nervoso
autônomo Mas pode estar associado a
condições como hipertiroidismo
diabetes destos hormonais algumas
infecções suor com Cheiro muito forte
pode ser problemas metabólicos ou
infecções
o suor amarelado esverdeado ou azulado
podem sinalizar uma condição Rara
chamada crom
o suar intenso noturno pode estar
associado a infecções câncer ou
distúrbios
hormonais sudorese repentina intensa
pode ser sinal de ataque cardíaco em
alguns
casos tá então as manchas amarelas
camisetas são um problema
comum mesmo usando desodorantes
naturais e essa questão da cor aí é
geralmente causado pelo pela reação
entre proteínas do suor e composto de
alumínio presente antitranspirantes mas
tá falando que você não tá usando
desodorante com
alumínio porém outros fatores podem
contribuir como óleos corporais resíduos
de
produtos de higiene ou bactérias na pele
então para prevenir essas manchas
amarelas use camisetas de tecidos
naturais como algodão que são mais
respiráveis Lave as camisetas logo após
você usar para evitar que o sor Fix no
tecido considere usar uma camiseta de
algodão por baixo da roupa que você tá
utilizando para absorver o suor e
aplique menos odorante e deixe secar
completamente antes de vestir a camiseta
beleza
Jurandir algum tratamento natural que
baixe
PSA bem aí você pode usar curcumina Você
pode ter bons atos de vida com atividade
física regular Uma alimentação
balanceada rica em vegetais embaixo em
açúcar e carboidratos
refinados controlar o estresse também
pode ajudar e us o dis suplementos como
eu caso de sal palmeto zinco cente de
abóbora Ortiga de oica licopeno só que
nem sempre esses recursos funcionam para
baixar o PSA Tá bom então nem sempre
você vai ter esse efeito que você
quer pessoa também não se identificou vi
uma notícia que o nutrólogo falou que as
notícias que as dúvidas se o óleo de
coco pode mesmo curar osá óleo de coco
não cura o zá tá eu sei que tem que
livro da Mary Newport
eh mesmo esse marido dela que é o Steve
Newport ele teve uma melhora 5 horas de
coco mais anos depois ele teve essa pior
assim a última notícia que eu tenho de
2013 que ele tinha piorado da doença Tá
então não vá com essa informação de que
sozinho resolve azim que eu nunca vi
nenhum caso na minha experiência depois
de ver centenas de pacientes com essa
doença e tão pouco o Steven e o port
realmente ficou bem mesmo só ficou teve
uma melhora Inicial Depois voltou a
piorar tá então essa história do h de
pouco ele ajuda mas sozinho ele não
resolve nada tá
e sempre que eu como doces biscoitos
sinto como se surgisse catarro na
garganta e quando espio sinto que tem
catarro agora acontece até com alimentos
saudáveis e que pode ser devo
preocupar pode ser várias coisas pode
ser refluxo G esofágico pode ser
produção excessiva de muco então
importante você investigar com o médico
se você tem refluxo que pode ser
gastroesofágico ou faringo larino
pode ser uma Legi intolerância alimentar
que tem que ser investigado
também ou pode ser uma Rin sinusite
crônica né a sinusite crônica pode levar
a gotejamento pós-nasal onde o excesso
de muco produzido no nariz e também que
vem do seio paranasal escorre para a
garganta também pode ser uma laringite
crônica Então tem que ser avaliado no
consultório médico
casa é um
caso
thgo o Dr AX fez um vídeo sobre como
reverter doença
autoimunes são várias coisas porém com
relação à dieta até mesmo alguns
alimentos saudáveis são restritos
segundo a recomendação dele na sua
opinião uma vez a doença autoimune
revertida ela pode voltar caso Continue
com hábitos
saudáveis porém não é exatamente o plano
usado para reverter a doença então
várias dietas que são usadas para
doenças autoimunes uma delas é a
paleolítica autoimune Elas têm várias
fases tem uma fase mais
rigorosa e você tem uma fase que é feita
uma
eh uma liberação lenta de alguns
alimentos tá então você pode fazer isso
pode fazer uma dieta mais rigorosa né
paleolítico autoimune e depois você pode
ir aos pouquinhos e reintroduzindo
alguns alimentos tá mas se você voltar a
comer como a maioria das pessoas comem
certamente essa doença aimun vai Volt
então nunca coma digamos assim
normal mesmo depois de você flexibilizar
a dieta com outros alimentos que vão ser
reintroduzidos e tem que ser
monitorizado continuamente aí por médico
tá sabendo dessa dessas estratégias aí
OK e é muito importante também fazer o
gerenciamento do estresse
[Música]
a bicicleta para exercício ela pode ser
de marcha ou deve ser sem marcha Depende
se você vai fazer poucos minutos de
exercício físico na bicicleta não
precisa ter com marcha agora se você vai
andar muitos quilômetros com a bicicleta
e em diferentes terrenos diferentes
inclinações é melhor que você tenha uma
bicicleta com marcha tá então você pode
começar primeiro com 15 minutos por dia
de de uso da bicicleta se você não tiver
experiência E aí você vai aumentando aos
pouquinhos o tempo
tá E aí você vai aumentando aos
pouquinhos o tempo você aumentar o
condicionamento físico agora se você já
tiver andando mais de uma hora com a
bicicleta aí convém você comprar uma
bicicleta que tenha marchas investir um
pouco mais de dinheiro
nisso então seria além de 30 km ou além
de uma hora aí de bicicleta você
adquiria uma bicicleta que tenha mais
sofisticação aí com marchas
tá importante é você começar a devagar
isso e subindo aos poucos da
intensidade Quais exames para ver a
saúde da vesícula biliar e quais
sintomas que a integrativa
indica para problemas exames ult tração
de abdômen total exames de função
hepática TJ GP Gama GT fosfatase
alcalina
bilirubinas desidrogenase lática são os
principais exames
e você pode também eventualmente alguns
casos que tem suspeita de cálculo de
colédoco de de vias bilias tem um exame
especial chamado CPRE mas é só pessoas
que tem realmente suspeita de cálculo
impactado no nas vias
biliares tá então são esses esses os
exames sintomas Você pode ter quería se
você tiver cálculo impactado n vias
biliares se tiver só cálculo na vesícula
não vai ter que ter Isa mas pode ter Dor
embaixo da costela do lado direito que
aumenta quando você come mais gordura ou
come alimentos mais
pesados Você pode ter digestão mais
lenta se tiver com pedra visícula
dificuldade de digestão ou até mais
gases por conta disso porque vai
proliferar mais bactéria porque vai
sobrar mais nutriente
[Música]
na que da alimentação vai ser digerido é
basicamente isso daí
tá qual a utilidade medicinal do ibisco
o ibisco geralmente é usado como
diurético natural
tá essa é a
principal uso do hibisco você acentar
alguma coisa é o Hibisco também é
utilizado muito em em regime né pessoal
que tá em
como diurético né como
termogênico e tem um um alguns países
usam muito chá do hibisco como
substituto de sucos né Principalmente os
da da da América
Central Então pergunta ao vivo da Estela
aqui uma fassa manipulou min niacina e
não colocou o no Flash no flush né no
caso é é só trocar lá pelo estou
apresentando o flush sempre que tomo e
volto ao normal depois de uma hora isso
é normal Estela já tive isso umas 200
vezes né Ana você já viu né os meus
flushes até os pacientes já viram várias
vezes aí sendo um peru de verdade é só
chato viu é chato mas não é nada que vai
causar problemas não Estela uma coisa
importante só Estela para te falar do
ponto de vista farmacêutico é assim
ã a diferença do flush do no flush
muitas vezes tem a ver com o valor
também tá então às vezes o paciente fala
olha eu pedi uma manipulação tava x e no
outro tava Y quando tem uma diferença
muito grande tiver eh ancina no flush
cuidado muitas vezes eles colocam brafo
por leve Tá mas única coisa quando é
muito intenso o paciente começa a passar
mal que liga se o paciente não é
alérgico à aspirina né a gente pede para
tomar uma aspirina infantil Tá bom mas
não leva nenhum efeito deletério a longo
prazo não até bom vai causa vaso de lata
que é bom pro organismo Mas é bem
desconfortável Pelo menos eu acho de
várias vezes ser feito e eu até parei de
usar o a niacina comum no flush aliás
comum que é de flush D flush que é da da
Life extension inclusive né Não mas
podia ser qualquer outra fonte Já tomei
nass manipulada ou ou da Life extension
os dois deram flush sim e aí vai te
enchendo o saco isso daí Aí eu acabei
desistindo tomar por causa
disso o sabonete febo da Granada é
saudável para mim é agora não pesquisei
profundamente a parte se tem algum
estudo falando do sabonete FEB eu acho
ele muito agradável esse sabonete e ele
que Até onde eu sei ele é um sabonete
feito com ingredientes naturais é é um
sabonete feito com
glicerina eu gosto muito para paciente
que às vezes tem o problema dele só é
que ele
a o odor dele ele tem ele é super antigo
né isso aí nossos pais nossos avós
gostavam bastante Ele dá muita ardência
então paraa região de olhos região
genital se tiver algum cor ele pode
arder muito se você tá preferindo usar
algum produto da Granado Particularmente
eu gosto muito do sabonete de glicerina
aquele Amarelinho em líquido o normal ou
de calêndula né e o líquido bom é que
ele ele o ele dura muito mais né porque
esses sabonetes glicerinados eles vão
ficando
bem vão derretendo bastante com o tempo
né E tem uma linha muito boa agora que é
o é o Dora da orosa eora eora eora tá a
gente tá eu usei o protetor solar deles
h o desodorante de desodorante o
desodorante deles é é excepcional eu
nunca vi um desodorante natural tão bom
para é um bastão né é de todos que eu
conheço aí eu já usei uns quatro cinco
diferentes Esse daí é o melhor em termos
assim de bloquear o dor sem
eh eu nunca vi um desodorante natural
tão eficaz quanto ele para bloquear o
dor da é hora que é um bastãozinho que
você enfia na passa na axila viu ô
Estela Na verdade essa vaso de dilatação
até ajuda na atividade física viu você
colocou aqui fica mais rápido na Cora
Pode sim aumentar o tá performance pela
vasodilatação tá só que você vai ficar
vermelha que nem o pimentão mas fora
isso inclusive muitos e atletas usam sim
ancina além
da da própria alanina para causar vaso
de dilatação
na pode usar lanina pode usar ancina e
também pode usar
para vase dilatação
a a citrulina também né a agina também
causa esse efeito de vaso
dilatação Obrigado Estela aí pelas
palavras
eh gentis
tá quando urino e a água do chuveiro cai
em cima do da urina no caso né fica com
espuma o que isso pode ser pode não ser
nada é bom você fazer um exame de urina
para identificar se você tá com uma
infecção ou se tem excesso de proteína
na urina também mas não só por fato de
fazer espuma não quer necessariamente
quer dizer que você tá doente não
pessoal nós passamos de uma hora de Live
tá eu sei que tem umas dúvidas ao vivo
aqui eu vou pedir pro Eliseu pegar essa
suas dúvidas elizel e colocar no
documento da semana que vem
tá pra gente poder responder com calma
na semana que
vem agradeço aí a presença de vocês um
beijo no coração de todos nós nos vemos
na próxima semana hoje como teve muita
pergunta no documento
eh não vai dá para responder as que
estão ao vivo aqui tá eu respondi por
acaso aqui da Estela porque tava na
minha cara aqui tá mas vocês que
colocaram dúvidas aqui ao vivo deixem
essas dúvidas copie e cola essas dúvidas
e coloca no documento da semana que vem
tá bom
pessoal eu vou tentar é que nas
terças-feiras Geralmente eu tô na ABC né
se o doutor trocar para outro dia as
lives eu até consigo entrar mais à vees
dif é porque isso foi votação eles
preferiram se eles quiserem fazer outra
votação para outro dia não tem problema
mas eh isso foi decidido por eles mesmos
de fazer as lives na
terça-feira tá não esqueçam de se
inscrever no canal não inscrit no canal
só para terminar de engraçado Então tá
bom Eliseu Segura a onda aí tá pega suas
perguntas e coloca um documento da
semana que vem
abraço a todos nós nos vemos na semana
que vem beijo no coração de todos
vocês fazer uma uma uma